do you think chess will ever get solved
from the opening position to where we'll
know the optimal optimal level of play I
highly doubt it
um without major advances in Quantum
Computing I don't think it's realistic
to expect chess to be hard solved I just
I don't think that will happen
um but I I don't know it could happen 20
30 years maybe but I think in the near
future it's not not realistic well then
let's go up with the Pod head follow-up
question suppose it does get solved what
opening do you think would be the
optimal well everything will be a draw
for sure after for sure after move one
yes for sure absolutely you're
absolutely sure of that yes yeah that's
what why are you so sure I'm so sure
because when you look at the computer
games you see these decisive results
it's because they played the openings
are set generally they can't they can't
for move one they Place set opens like
you might play the Knight or you might
play the Berlin defense normally it's
set openings as opposed to
um as opposed to computers being able to
do whatever they want I just believe in
general when the openings that are
symmetrical like E4 E5 D4 D5 uh the
computers will draw and I think the
optimal opening I think E4 E5 Knight F3
Knight F6 is probably a guaranteed draw
if there is perfect if we have perfect
information and we know that that
chassis solved e45 Knight F3 Knight F6
the Russian or the Petrov defense that
that will be the optimal strategy see so
that's sure of that symmetrical play
is going to lead to a draw but what if
you can constantly as white maintain
asymmetry constantly keep the opponent
off balance so yes E4 then then you're
all you're always doing this symmetry
but what if chess inherently there's
something about the mathematics of the
game that allows
for like that thin line that you walk
that maintains to the end game the
asymmetry constantly that there's no
move that can
uh bring bring back the balance of the
game
yeah I I don't think that exists I don't
think it does so basically I'm saying E4
E5 I think it's a draw I think D4 D5 is
a draw C4 C5 I think I think basically
symmetry that's all of it's a draw I
think that's that's why it's a draw so
it doesn't even matter like you're
saying what one if it's solved
most openings will be a draw yes I think
E4 D4 C4 and Knight F3 for sure will be
a draw other openings I'm not sure about
but those first four uh possible
starting moves I think chess is a draw
Knight F3 what's the response to Knight
F3
um probably a knight F6 again
make it simple
if I play Knight of three I'll move one
um black here can also play D5
I'll move one and normally at some point
White's gonna end up playing D4 so the
order of so it's probably going to lead
back yeah all roads kind of lead back
there as well there probably are other
ways which
um where there is play but I think
that's at the end of the day the
Symmetry is symmetry is what's going to
lead lead to like a forced forced
equality or Draw on the game of Truss